let's see if you got what it takes to
work for ganym Elon Musk okay because
because this is what Elon has six rules
to work for him Tom how about we read
this uh six rules to people who maybe
are sitting there saying I got a lot of
confidence man what would it take for me
to work with Elon here's Elon six rules
all right here we go number one okay
elon's musk six rules would you survive
working for Elon musk's Forbes no large
meetings the first of the rules I must
recommend is to avoid large meetings he
says excessive meanings are the blight
of big companies that almost always get
worse over time please get off all large
meetings unless you're certain they're
providing value uh to the whole audience
number two no long or frequent meetings
related to the ban on large meetings
musk says get rid of frequent meetings
unless you're dealing with an extremely
urgent matter meeting frequency should
drop rapidly once the Urgent matter is
resolved don't be afraid to leave musk
recommends that people walk walk out of
a meeting or drop out drop off a call as
soon as it's obvious that you are no
longer adding value it is not rude to
leave it's rude to make someone stay and
waste their time number four no acronym
or jargons his rule about communication
is don't use acronyms or nonsense words
for object softwares or processes in
general anything that requires an
explanation inhibits communication we
don't want people to have to memorize a
glossary just to function five ignore
the chain of command musk Advocates that
people ignore the chain of command and
that communication should be travel via
the shortest path necessary to get the
job done six use common sense finally my
success in general always pick common
sense as your guide if following a
company rule is obviously ridiculous in
a particular situation such that it
would make for a great Dilbert cartoon
than rules then the rules should change
by the way these six rules only
apply if the founder is involved it's
six rules yeah don't apply if the CEO is
involved because an active CEO doesn't
mind it if you move chain of command and
just go directly and deal with the issue
but an inactive CEO that's working and
kind of like doing his own thing they
don't want you to be going to them for
everything so this is a very interesting
perspective that he's got Tom any
thoughts on uh on Elon Musk oh I love
this because it points toward efficiency
and I'm kind of curious is what's
flowing in the chats right now and
people's reaction to this I look at it
and there's three things in here that
jump out to me actually actually there's
two and there's a third the one is about
meetings meetings have to have a purpose
I mean I love what Amazon does Jeff
Bezos tells people in meetings they have
to be really short he has a staff
meeting once a week that apparently
covered all the divisions of Amazon in
less than 90 minutes that's a freaking
Amazon people come in there they're
really really repaired prepared and he
used to say hey that answer starts with
the number and ends with the date don't
tell me you send emails don't somebody
make calls and some of the other stuff
just tell me what's up and start with
the number and end with the day you've
always done that by the way I well by
the way I when I read that in the book I
said that's brilliant you know and so I
think this is very there's a lot of
efficiency and if you work for somebody
that is ruthlessly putting efficiency on
the table so that you can be working on
solution and adding value it's
tremendous what's the audience saying no
they're they're agreeing with you by the
way if you're if you're somebody that
reports the time you're going to become
a better I've seen Tom this over the
years over and over and over I don't I
don't know if I agree with all these
things with me I know you don't I don't
know I mean uh look go ahead give us
your perspective on what you disagree
with all right no large meetings all
right we have a monthly entire
valuetainment staff meeting all right I
think that's there's value in that the
entire staff comes together yep I mean I
get it if you're a Tesla you have how
many thousand employees I I completely
appreciate that but I think from time to
time having a large meeting is a good
thing to have the whole company together
whether that's a 10 person company a 50
company freaking PHP does a 10 000
people meeting
annual event so I think that's kind of
in that out so I I kind of disagree with
musk on that I will also say this
there's a couple things here that will
you could lose your job for doing number
three don't be afraid to leave the
meeting okay sure Pat okay sure Elon
yeah hey guys we're all having a meeting
and some guy goes hey Pat listen I guess
thanks for the meeting I'm gonna go
peace out where do you think you're
going buddy I don't know if I agree with
that okay so that's like easier said
than done if you're the CEO be like I
don't want to go to the meeting like
versus the guy that just started two
weeks ago excuse me Mr mosque I'm gonna
go ahead this meetings
I agree with you okay yeah and last
thing here ignore the chain of command
okay buddy yeah sure just yeah I know my
boss told me to do this I'm supposed to
report there's a part of that fight
there's a part of that I agree with
really let me explain to you Mario
listen up no no but there's a partner
and he would agree with it there's a
part of it I agree with uh uh uh here's
and it's twofold so I'll give you a
perspective see how you process this
number one sometimes managers move slow
to get information up it drives me
insane and I'll say and I'll flat out
tell them I see how come I don't know
about how come it's been three weeks
since I've known about this
can you tell me why I don't know but I'm
the CEO of the company you haven't told
me this for three weeks why don't I know
about this and then I'll go to the
person that found out about it first and
when they told the c-suite so then I'll
say the accountability isn't on the guy
that reported to the c-suite then I'll
say c-suite how come you've been sitting
on this for three weeks what is this all
about why have you been sitting on this
for three weeks we could have resolved
this three weeks ago and this you know
issue could have been a lot smaller if
we resolved it through so sometimes this
makes sense depending on who the manager
is some managers work very quickly some
leaders work very quickly others sit on
issues I actually agree with the part of
sometimes uh uh they they sit on these
types of issues and then the other part
is in certain environments not all
certain leaders and managers are very
insecure very insecure and this is what
I mean by insecurity so let's just say
you know uh he Vinnie reports to you
okay and you're a guy that's a 459 guy
you get off every day at 450. now you
can't wait to go home and Fridays you
leave at one o'clock because you got
golf tea time two o'clock right and you
put your nice very high short shorts on
and tight you know you know okay
in Farsi they call those shorts
you wear those shorts yeah and you go
out and Miami called Daisy Dukes
that's what it was in Farsi so you go
Vinnie Friday stays till seven o'clock
gets his project done gets everything
done sends the email with his reports
for the week you're golfing right
some managers want to Shield me from
knowing how hard Vinnie's working to
take all the credit for themselves in
those types of cases I also want to know
who Vinny is because Vinnie may have a
better career at a company than you may
he may move up higher than you but
sometimes managers that are not giving
their best they Shield their best people
so there's a part of that that I agree
with on what he's saying the part about
walking up I agree with you
number one that's why Vinnie was the
Airman of the year I mean clearly that's
because you know his exceeding
expectations but one thing I'll
definitely say that I've learned from
you is when it comes to communication
Bob you're talk you talk about over
communicating what just happened yeah
I'm listening all right
but you like in any relationship the key
is communication you've heard that a
million times but you talk about over
communicate like there's always those
times where it's like
something happened whatever it is it's
like should I tell patch I tell the boss
I don't it's kind of annoying I'm gonna
kind of be in trouble but like
you kind of you're like ah [ __ ] it I
don't want to deal with it and you don't
send a text you don't send a message
you're like ah let's just sweep this
under the rug and just kind of do the
whole ostrich like you know while the
coyote thing and just forget it's not
gonna happen
but then the boss finds out you're like
[ __ ] so what you kind of encourage is
over communicate get ahead of the issue
Hey listen by the way we had this issue
yeah you know we got overcharged it was
an issue there's a there was an editing
situation FYI and that way you can get
ahead of it there is value and by the
way so somebody's listening to this now
saying that's exactly my problem I got a
boss who doesn't realize how special I
am and that's it that's my problem why I
don't get the promotions relax bro
because the market eventually finds out
if you're badass I promise you the
Market's going to find that there is Art
and diplomacy there is a lot of value in
diplomacy and you know the other day we
had an event a meeting and I get uh
calls
and I I get calls and people say let me
tell you man
tikrin showed diplomacy in a way I've
never seen before I love that guy he was
so diplomatic respectful to everybody he
protected the company he protected the
field he protected the clients he
protected the employees and he called
out everybody at the same time in a very
diplomatic way right there is a value in
learning how to be diplomatic I
guarantee you
if tigrant has anything to worry about
he keeps incred he never ever has to
worry about having a job or being of
value anywhere if he learns the art of
Being diplomatic I think that's the one
area that some employees I want to be
managers don't put a lot of emphasis in
I think you ought to also learn how to
be diplomatic not just jump in the gun
and wanting to [ __ ] at everybody and
say my boss is not this throwing them
under the bus that's also not an
attractive quality because anytime
somebody comes up to me bitching about
their boss I'm turned off by it it's
just there's nothing attractive about it
so what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
[Music]